hey guys how's it going today we are
doing something very very fun I'm with
my sister Jenna hello and usually we
don't really do Christmas gifts anymore
I mean we kind of do but like not like
we used to so today we decided that we
bought each other Christmas gifts and
obviously when you give someone a
Christmas gift they don't know what's in
the gift but today we're going to
blindfold each other open up our gifts
and see if we can guess what they are
and clearly Jenna's already okay I mean
I accidentally touched it it's like
Emily Stewart a messed up but it's okay
you don't know what's on it yeah I don't
I don't I don't on it but I kept
stepping on it for weeks over there
which I my good to get a butterfingers
and steady um so what are we I'm doing
okay so we're gonna let's set these
aside and then we're each gonna like
open one and then try to guess and then
that's really it those first do we do
one at a time well how many did you get
me and so oh okay I got you five as well
oh really I think so you go first since
welcome to Mike welcome to you open this
one left okay know what it says don't
ask questions just open the present okay
I'm gonna guess with this is a horrible
careful why is it so quickly you didn't
get porcupine no it's a very very
uncomfortable doormat its doormat it's a
doormat yep every time you come into my
house walking all over with your little
like said my mess and your shoes and
your poopy shoes does it say something
on here
there's a yes that said there's like a
there's a picture of something what is
your favorite thing Maddy
well okay yeah but like when you buy a
t-shirt like what do you always get on
your t-shirt goals other than holes
pocket no anytime there's like a design
like what do you always buy every shirt
you have has one of these on every shirt
I have there's a design on this are no
think about what you always have on your
freaking shirt what size shirt like
which one do I have like tons of them
like Alexander that's my girl
oh my brain is slow I think the
gingerbread has injured me I think so I
see it oh it's very nice I was left is s
so damn awesome we'll Kroy with my
gingerbread what's wrong with you freak
okay there you go don't touch me there
you go no relevance to really anything
but I did a kitchen runner you wish no
relevance anything is it a robe okay oh
is it a blanket now is it a onesie maybe
Oh what kind of one who do you think it
won't think it's a cow what I'm
inappropriate it feels like where's the
top whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
I can't believe it oh yeah let me get
you this little teeny tiny one I hope
it's a stack of money be a small stack
an opening if you have it she's open an
ish okay
don't be peeking okay no peeking in the
fortune chase it is a keychain smell it
does it have a smell
yeah but what is it we smell it smells
like a Reagan Oh our basil is it I don't
know what does it smell like show the
camera what it is what is it smell it
again it smells like what it is oregano
people like what do you put oregano on
anything could you give me a walking
piece open up open up your eyeballs
how are you creeping in my Amazon no but
but it's supposed it has a smell it
smells like pizza
ow like it's a sitting injured on this
video Oh what is this
those are made the other side well okay
what color oh my god the probably plan
no are they black
yeah what other color gray Yoma know
things like a champion champion sauce
did I get in there socks
yeah oh yes I'm super fast there I
didn't think I didn't keep out of this
oh yes oh they're thick too for my thick
body be ready a giant took the role yes
it is new be so cool but unwrapped a
puppy bunny is it a dog that was not
planned at all oh my god Oh Holly in
shock I'm like but there's a panic and
I'm like this is a dog rip some rock yes
yes si bonito
meters very clean yeah you're dirty nice
very bonito yeah but I want a counter
for that it's like this is something
that I ever gonna do my mommy help you
down
oh thank ya come on this love may bleep
around me I'm gonna help you done you're
gonna have to like a lot of time on the
improv well I can't see it anyway
so this feels like is it a mug yeah
is it a shot glass yeah is it something
to me you should know oh okay
is it breakable yeah but like oh really
this feels like something I put my
iPhone in okay this is correct okay
feels like a bone yeah you feeling I'm
feeling oh yes
okay there is a port okay it's uh should
I plug this into my car you do but why
is it a fan wait that's me that's
doesn't make no makes a lot of fans
you're gonna it to your iPhone in
the car it's gonna charge yes yes well
yeah yes do you think it'll charge with
the cord or Wireless this is my car for
a month now
well we could enjoy one but you have one
- yes I bought - one for me and then
I've been using it in my car for
masteries I haven't seen that in there
my gift me another alright okay this is
a gash hopes real people in a real dog
I felt that strap okay
it has a very I don't like the texture
of it okay well this is a separate step
this is a fanny pack no think about like
when you go to school and you need to
pack something separate a lunchbox
yes house whole but I do bring snacks of
jail time you do license the guess what
kind
so there's characters on it and they are
teenagers Turtles yeah thing but you got
a look you got it you got a you got a
look at what's on it oh my god one thing
when you were like I hope there's a
pizza well my father is I am you are
like crazy it's very shiny
yeah it's I'm gonna look super cold in a
neighborhood look you can put your
little cooler snacks in you like it's a
little insulated oh that's very nice I
know you could bring your snacks around
thanks Jeff welcome yeah all right
you're up
oh that's my turn okay the best one yet
is it really oh yes okay let me
blindfold myself I I will kill you I
will I'm going to get some frickin
clouds it's the cloud your city guys
don't know Jenna and Ed have been hiding
these around my house like crazy and so
recently I took it to ROS house I hid
one there and then she took that one and
then hit it in Kandi's makeup container
it's so crazy I find them everywhere
like I went to bed and I woke up and I
was like oh my god that's clown on my
bed how did it get there Jenna I can't
believe it I can't believe it that was
so good Olli I thought you were gonna do
that to me I hope that you enjoy this
it's a Lego it's a president singing it
as a handle it does have a handle well
Pat has a power yes it does what a
flashlight oh my gosh goodness gracious
no with a big one like really else do
you mean help you here I'll show you if
you open it for me yeah I remember my
dad oh there you go really big
flashlights a pancake a waffle maker
yeah but what kind of maker is it how it
makes a pizza waffle no I got my eye
there's poison in there just give it a
touch see if you can figure out what it
kind of maker this is wait let me see if
I can feel it you know what it is yeah
but I'm just seeing if I could blue as
difficult yeah that's difficult okay so
hear me start here okay like an eighth
weird it's a pretzel it's like a weird
name open your eyes
wait I bought has one big breath dog was
that it was confusing
oh my it's a particle makers you make
clothes and I was making waffle pretzel
shape waffles is that you can't do but
it's a pretzel maker oh this is now
we're talking oh free video idea bow
this video right to be honest I had to
forgive I was gonna buy this and I was
gonna make the video and I was like this
is a great video for Jenna because she
loves pretzels if you guys Aoki oh so
now you got a video idea and a present
oh is this the kitchen runner no oh but
wow this big yeah this is big
the camera Oh what is the feeling
what is this okay there you go what in
the world feel it all around fully
overall size of it overall shape it's
very big
is this something is this like a put on
your head yeah you cut it put four I
have absolutely no idea what this is
okay alright so think about it like
you're putting something in it I'm
putting this on myself it's this shape
it's the shape of the something
what is this shape like close your eyes
and like feel it like what's at the top
here a crown some type of maybe like a
friend Oh like uh yes a pineapple what a
pineapple pinch ok so put your there's a
hole inside of it right down here
so what could go in there oh my goodness
probably won't like it though he's gonna
hate it but you never know he might like
it when I looked really big on the
internet so I guess Maddie's not that
big but it happens oh well anyway Wow we
this is a really great gift I am very
very excited about but it's a blankie oh
my gosh yeah I know he's gonna be into
it but we'll shove him in there
well even I feel like we could take this
out to like just put his little blankie
then there's more room for puppet
pineapple pins you can go in there oh
hey love it yeah I'd say put that back
in cuz it was out of shape you put it
back in a while Wow well guys thanks so
much for watching make sure you go check
out Jenna's channel and stay tuned for
her pretzel making video because I feel
like that's gonna be quite entertaining
people don't link in the description to
all these lovely products on Amazon yes
whether you know bonus bonus thank you
guys for watching happy holidays I've
got a bunch more videos coming up unless
this is the Christmas video then I may
not have any more I'm not really sure I
haven't figured out the order of these
videos yet but happy holidays Merry
Christmas whatever it is that you
celebrate I hope that you're having a
wonderful time and I'm very
about these masks I'm excited about my
new uh now watch me with no as we call
me you always worse called we could
remember hmm small mind very small
alright see you guys later bye
thanks for my present thank you yes you
can have the backpack so you like it
[Music]